les spectateurs pour les citoyens pour
toutes les personnes qui assistent à
cette audition que l'office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques ou en
cours opnext ou office parlementaire
scientifique est un organe parlementaire
bicamérale 18 députés 18 sénateurs
je suis le président cédric villani le
sénateur gérard longuet ici présents et
le premier vice président et un bon
nombre de parlementaires de l'opex sont
ici présents pour cette audition qui
s'effectue dans le cadre d'une mission
sur la sur le kovy 19 et en particulier
sur la stratégie vaccinale mission dont
le président de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand nous a confié la bonne
garde
c'était temps c'était à l'automne
dernier une mission qui menait avec
quatre rapporteurs ici présents
représentant un panel de sensibilités
politiques qui lie à la sénatrice sonia
de la provôté l'union centriste
il y à la sénatrice florence lassarade
les républicains il ya le député gérard
le seul socialiste il ya le député jean
françois illy à ou la république en
marche tous les quatre présents ici pour
cette audition
ainsi qu'à leur côté un certain nombre
de députés et de sénateurs membres de
cette fils cette audition s'inscrit dans
un ensemble d'auditions et de comptes
rendus de rapport de l'opecst sts sur la
question de la stratégie vaccinale en
particulier le rapport qui a été
présenté le 15 décembre à la presse aux
parlementaires qui a été dans le débat
parlementaire sur la stratégie vaccinale
mais aussi le communiqué de presse du 11
janvier émis par le texte et ça
s'inscrit dans une mission qui va
continuer pendant les mois à venir pour
contrôler pour évaluer pour interpeller
les différentes institutions
responsables de l'ensemble de cette
stratégie vaccinale face au co vide
ce soir nous avons avec nous le
professeur jean françois desprez
delfraissy président du conseil
scientifique qui conseille le
gouvernement le président sur tous les
sujets liés au vide et en particulier
sur la stratégie vaccinale mais pas que
le titre du dernier rapport du conseil
scientifique qui disait entre vaccins et
variant à une course contre la montre
montre bien à quel point la question du
coc vide est maintenant complètement
imbriqués avec la question de la
vaccination contre le coc vide et
aujourd'hui nous auront tout le loisir
de parler précisément de ceux de ce
rapport et de la situation actuelle on a
vu une actualité qui a été mouvementée
on a entendu parler des déboires liés à
la fourniture par astrazeneca
on a deux les les positions les
hésitations peut-être de certaines
institutions sur l'espacement des doses
dans la vaccination les les comparaisons
internationales le contexte actuel qui
est plein de plein d'actualité et nous
aurons l'occasion d'évoquer tout cela
merci beaucoup
le professeur delfraissy ils vont être
rendus disponibles pour cette audition
et dans le cadre de ce travail capital
pour la pour la démocratie pour le
travail parlementaire pour la
représentation de l'assemblée nationale
et du sénat peut-être avant que je vous
passe la parole pour un propos liminaire
si le sénateur gérard longuet veut dire
quelques mots aussi avec micro c'est mon
micro est branché non à dire vrai je
crois que nous devons aller à
l'essentiel et nous avons la chance
d'avoir ici on va lui donner la parole
immédiatement
c'est parfait professeurs comme je vous
propose proposer un petit exposé
liminaire d'une dizaine de minutes qui
permettra ensuite aux parlementaires de
rebondir à vous la parole
bonjour à tous merci pour cette
invitation à débattre si je peux dire
avec le pex donc jean françois
delfraissy je suis médecin je suis
professeur d'immunologie émérite à paris
saclay j'ai dirigé longtemps l' agence
nationale de recherches sur le sida et
les hépatites puis ensuite je me suis
yeux très impliqués dans les maladies
émergentes en particulier d'henri bola
et donc j'ai été nommé
brillant du de ce comité scientifique
que vides début mars 2001 sur lequel on
pourra revenir je suis fondamentalement
d'aucun un médecin et un scientifique
qui a dirigé une unité inserm
je ne suis pas comme on me présente
souvent un conseiller médical qui a
suivi les présidents successifs il se
trouve qu'il ya eu plusieurs reprises
successives mais mon métier de base et
qui reste mon métier j'ai encore une
consultation à bicêtre
c'est d'être un médecin et auprès des
patients alors plutôt que de vous parler
du passé je vous parlais de ceux de
notre vision actuelle au niveau du
conseil scientifique
enfin fin décembre quand je présentais
un peu le finalement sur un topo un peu
général de deux seuls de ce drame de
cette pandémie j'avais un sorte de
tragédie en trois actes
la première qui correspondait à la
première vague la seconde de la deuxième
vague et la troisième qui débutait à
partir de janvier 2021 et qui était
finalement la sortie un peu de cette
tragédie avec avec l'arrivée des vaccins
plus rapidement qu'on ne l'avait imaginé
et qu'il nous menait après des
stratégies vaccinales qui est états à
mettre en place et et qu'on s'a les
comptes de toute façon on savait
d'avancé qu'elle serait longue qui
pouvait nous mener à une sorte
d'immunité en population pour l'été et
donc avec une sortie de crise je dirais
à l'automne 2009 un tiers
et puis juste avant noël tout a changé
c'est confiant mais malheureusement tout
début janvier avec l'arrivée des
variants et je vous rappelle très vite
hein mais vous savez qu'on a en même
temps l'arrivée de plusieurs variants en
variant que j'appellerais uk je vais je
vais les appeler par leur nom de pays ce
qui n'est pas bien et qui est plus
simple que si je vous inflige le 501 y z
3 etc aux quelques est plus complexe
mais ce n'est pas bien parce
qu'évidemment il ya une sorte de forme
d'ostracisme
en parlant de ça c'est bien on sait bien
on se souvient tous les débats sur
l'appellation grippe espagnole
voilà n'avait rien d'espagnol et c'est
sans vraiment attention
alors on va parler quand même néanmoins
de l'udc et qui est apparue vous le
savez fin septembre en angleterre puis
qui a progressé très rapidement les
anglais ont des capacités de séquençage
importante donc l'ont mis en évidence
d'une part cette pénétration en
particulier dans la région de l'ombre et
dans le sud est de l'angleterre puis son
extension et ont rapidement finalement
montré qu'il avait un niveau de
transmission qui était plus élevé si on
part d'un la r10 classique un pur je
dirais le pari en normal c'est à dire
l'absence de variants eh bien on estime
que le variant angles est à 1.4 il n'est
pas plus pathogène 1 contrairement à ce
qui a été un peu annoncé il ya eu des
doutes au départ sur sa capacité de
transmission élevé ce que c'était un
fait scientifique ou est-ce que c'était
une utilisation politique par le
gouvernement anglais ya eu discussion au
niveau des médecins des épidémiologique
sur le sujet maintenant les choses sont
claires il ya véritablement un facteur
de transmission élevé ce qui a conduit
donc à une majorité de ce variant de
marion un pari dans deux mines qui est
devenu majoritaire et est donc avec un
niveau de transmission et donc avec un
niveau de contamination est donc avec
une surcharge du système de soins que
vous connaissez à l'ombre et qui a
conduit d'angleterre à se confiner de
façon drastique à partir juste de noël
relevons aussi que l'angleterre était
avec des des conditions de précaution
sanitaires beaucoup moins élevées que
celles qui étaient en france et ça reste
ça reste vrai sur le fond en boîtier sur
le port du masque sur l'ouverture d'un
certain de de l'exposition donc on était
dans un modèle différent
ce variant eux il après trois semaines
de presque quatre semaines de
confinement il commence à voir la courbe
se casser à londres
je rappelle qu'il ya eu avec un décalage
eu l'aval chose en irlande avec un
décalage de 15 jours à 3 semaines aussi
à voile l'augmentation burki
et qu'on a un autre modèle qui est très
difficile aussi c'est le modèle
portugais
à l'occasion des fêtes de noël et du
jour de l'an il y ait beaucoup de je
dirais d'interpénétration avec des
portugais qui travaillent en dehors du
portugal le variant où il est arrivé il
était à 6 % la première semaine à 14 %
la deuxième semaine
il est à 23% la deuxième semaine donc ce
variant et est en france on a pour sa 6
thèmes de de surveillance via le
séquençage qui est moins moins élaborées
quand l'angleterre qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas non plus nuls comme je
l'entends parfois il ya une capacité de
séquençage qui est importante elle
devrait être augmentée elle elle est en
train de re il est en cours
d'augmentation d'ailleurs et il faut pas
opposer une stratégie de surveillance
via les tests pcr avec une stratégie de
séquençage il nous faut de la
surveillance avec terrasse pcr et du
séquençage et c'est vraiment les deux
qui est l'un appuyant l'autre alors on a
les derniers chiffres on a des enquêtes
une grande enquête qui a été réalisée
dans quelques vaches les 8 et 9 janvier
une deuxième enquête est réalisée hier
mais on a aussi des données en région
parisienne réalisé par l'ensemble des
laboratoires de virologie qui à
l'ensemble des techniques pour le
réaliser et globalement on est
maintenant pratiquement à 14% à paris on
est probablement autour de 9 à 10 % dans
la région sud de la france il ya une
grande hétérogénéité selon les régions
avec des régions qui sont beaucoup moins
touchés
c'est d'ailleurs le cas aussi en
angleterre où il ya aussaresses quand
même avec une série de régions qu'il ya
il ya des différences mais toutes les
régions s'empêcher d'y camper en france
mais avec des niveaux de pénétration du
virus qui est qui et warnia sur ceux de
la grande question évidemment vous avez
le ce de ce variant c est il sensible ou
vaccin la réponse immunitaire induite
dans les vaccins et la réponse est pour
l'instant oui très probablement ce sont
les données à la fois avec des deux
vaccins de type de type là mais reina ou
les données sont plutôt rassurantes de
la même façon que la neutralisation par
des cocktails
comme monoclonaux ou par des sérums de
sujets déjà ayant fait un qu'ovide et il
ya une neutralisation de qualité sur le
mariage le variant sud africain est
encore plus difficile si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi puisqu'il a une un
niveau de transmission qui est un petit
peu plus élevé que que le variant angles
est apparu des mois de novembre décembre
en afrique du sud l'afrique du sud un
réseau de recherche qui est de très haut
niveau qui s'est construit autour du vih
pratiquement le 15 pour cent des
patients d essai pivot de phase iii des
essais de modern art et de files heures
ont été réalisés en afrique du sud pour
vous montrer le le niveau que ça
représentait un réseau de très connu de
vaccinologie en particulier il
il a comme particularité lui des travail
avec un niveau de transmission
légèrement plus élevé que l'anglais
peut-être des formes cliniques un tout
petit peu différente et un tout petit
peu plus précoce donc
et enfin le dernier point est que
malheureusement une série de données
suggèrent que les anticorps monoclonal
ne le neutralisent pas et les des
anticorps de patients ayant fait un
qu'ovide ne neutralisent pas non plus
pour le vaccin c'est des données qui
sont le verre à moitié plein le verre à
moitié vide
certaines données suggèrent qu'ils aient
de neutralisation par les des sérums de
sujets qui ont été vaccinés
d'autres données en gros il ya trois
papiers qui sont sortis dans la dernière
semaine montrent qu'ils aillent perte de
sensibilité aux vaccins de l'ordre de
40% le variant brésilien il ya deux
types de brésiliens milliards on va
parler d'un seul parent d'engis pour
juste pour vérifier quand vous dites
perte de sensibilité vous entendez quoi
ici parcelles c'est à dire une perte
quand on analyse ensuite quand on prend
deux n'ont pas le virus sauvage mais
d'aider des souches qui ont été
reconstitués avec les mutations
correspondant au virus sauvage qu'on
prend ensuite des sérums de sujets qui
ont été vaccinés et ensuite quand on
compare la capacité de ces sérum à
neutraliser la souche ancestrales ou au
contraire la souce sud africaine eh bien
on s'aperçoit que les sérums donc c'est
bien une réponse anticorps uniquement de
céder des sujets vaccinés neutralise la
souche sud africaine mais avec une
diminution d'environ 40% en terme de
titre la souche brésilienne est donc
dans le nord et les forêts du brésil au
tour de manaus
c'est à peu près la même histoire que la
souche sud africaine elles émanent
neutralisé par des anticorps
neutralisants elle émane réalisé par les
anticorps de sujets ayant déjà fait un
que vides et allez on a très peu de
données sur la sensibilité au vaccin
alors ce qui est je reviendrai sur des
questions qui se posent à partir de là
mais et c'est la question qui se pose en
particulier pour la france là dans les
semaines qui viennent si on réfléchit
d'une sorte de philosophie de la
relation entre entre l'hôte et le virus
pourquoi ces variants sur vient-il
au bout d'un an de que vides quelle est
l'explication est ce qu'on est passé à
côté
deux variantes qui serait survenue de
façon antérieurs non il ya des systèmes
de surveillance de haut niveau au niveau
planétaire d'une série de laboratoire de
virologie sur le site de l'om est sous
ou d'autres très grands laboratoires qui
sait quand serait régulièrement et qui
sur baïse entre guillemets des
variations importantes de ce lieu subite
en permanence à il ya une petite
mutation qui ont été observées on est
peut-être à la 250ème la 300e mutation
mais aucune d'entre elles n'avait
entraîné de modification phénotypiques
c'est à dire se traduisent en soit par
une transmission accrue soit par une
pathogénicité accrue placé en
l'occurrence ceux dont on parle pour ces
variants c'est essentiellement un
facteur de transmission accrue
je vous rappelle air à 102,1 à 1.4 ou
1.5 ce qui est quand même extrêmement
significatif alors pourquoi pourquoi
c'est varié en bout d'un an
l'autre point d'intérêt et le fait que
le variant brasilia survient à manaus
manaus est considéré par les épidémies
his comme la ville qui avait atteint une
immunité en population qui était de
l'ordre de 70%
ça a été extrêmement touché par des
vagues successives dans des conditions
sanitaires très difficile au brésil
c'est une population très jeune à manaus
en général il ya eu beaucoup de décès
parmi les populations les plus âgées
mais l'immense majorité des cas était
survenu sur la population jeune et qui
avait été donc infectés avec la présence
d'anticorps c'est ce qu'on appelle cette
immunité en population
on se rappelle que l'objectif des
vaccins est d'arriver à et finalement il
dit militer en population de l'ordre de
70%
eh bien c'est ce qui a été obtenu à
manaus pourquoi ça marche pas pourquoi
manaus à 1
finalement l'arrivée d'un nouveau
variant qui n'est pas reconnue par les
anticorps précédent et ça pose la
question de la capacité du virus qui par
définition à des mutations un peu
aléatoire c'est l'avis de virus mais qui
peut être éventuellement dirigé par une
pression de sélection immunologique en
population ou au niveau individuel pour
sélectionner tel ou tel type de mutation
qui lui permet d'échapper entre
guillemets ce qu'on appelle un
échappement et militaires qui lui permet
d'échapper à finalement quelque chose
qui le neutralisent
alors pourquoi le variant sud africain
il a été évoqué que parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de patients immunodéprimés je
rappelle que l'afrique du sud est est le
pays qui a le plus en termes absolus le
plus grand nombre de patients vih qui
est traitée plus ou moins bien traité et
donc une des explications ont regretté
que c'est sa survie des plus vite chez
les patients emile allais privé l'autre
l'autre constatations ce n'est pas une
explication et le fait qu'au cap
on était on avait atteint 46 1%
d'immunité populationnelle et coca on
voit si on veut dire un virus qui
échappe également aux anticorps
neutralisants chez les sujets du cap
alors ça c'est évidemment sa scène un
petit trouble sur la relation je suivais
entre haute et aux tv par contre je vous
rassure ce n'est pas le cas le modèle ne
marche pas pour l'angleterre et le
variés anglais se comporte de façon très
différente et enfin la limite est
induite par les vaccins
a probablement une immunité plus forte
plus solide plus durable que l'immunité
induite par l'infection est le même et
donc c'est un élément qui est quand même
à prendre en compte dans ce tableau un
peu un peu gris que je vous donnais il
ya un élément positif qui est autour de
la réponse immune immunitaire induite
par le vaccin qui est probablement plus
forte que la réponse immunitaire induite
par l'infection
alors je termine rapidement pour
puissiez pour me poser des questions et
qu'en est-il au niveau français à partir
des premières données c'est à dire qu'en
france on a finalement une double
infection en ce moment on avait une
affection une circulation du virus à un
niveau relativement important
la france est plutôt bon élève dans la
situation actuelle au niveau européen
après n'était pas être passé par des
parts départ des périodes variables mais
qu'on le compare par rapport à
l'angleterre par rapport à l'allemagne
qui avait été très bons élèves qu'on
nous qu'on nous donnait en permanence
par rapport aux suisses par rapport aux
belges par rapport à l'espagne par
rapport au portugal l'état sanitaire je
dirais l'état de multiplicateurs eu lieu
ces et de contrôle de ce virus est
probablement plus adapté donc on a
affaire à une double circulation une
circulation du virus ancestrales et une
circulation du nouveau mutant qui
pénètre de façon rapide puisque je vous
dis on met à peu près 14 % en région
parisienne et je vois mal ce qui
pourrait l'arrêter entre guillemets mais
des mesures de couvre-feu permettent ont
permis de tenir cette situation qui est
déjà très limites en termes de
retentissement sur le système sanitaire
en termes d'occupation des lits en
termes de nouvelles hospitalisations et
des régions de france vous le savez
qu'ils sont en situation de tension
particulier en franche comté ont donc
dans le sud de la france
mais il ya aussi des situations qui sont
maintenus comme eux en région parisienne
par exemple où la situation et est
maintenu mais il arrivait du variant
quand on fait des projections et à
l'intérieur du conseil scientifique vous
le savez nous avons nous travaillons
avec avec des scientifiques qui sont des
modélisateurs et le conseil scientifique
qui travaille avec
bien sûr les membres des conseils
scientifiques mais chaque membre du
conseil scientifique est une tête de
pont de sa communauté et santé et
redescendez reversât communauté
scientifique donc les modèles ce ne sont
pas les modèles d'un seul homme
ces modèles d'une communauté qui a
derrière et avec plusieurs plusieurs
modélisateurs et nous montre que si on
suit leur en prenant quelque chose de
pente entre guillemets de type modèle
anglais eh bien on va se trouver dans
une situation à peu près à la mi mars
avec un virus extrêmement dominant avec
un facteur de transmission très élevé et
donc avec des conséquences sanitaires en
terme de deux spécialisations
d'hospitalisation en rire de 2,2 de
toucher la population la plus ancienne
et la plus fragile de façon importante
d'où la question posée avec l'arrivée de
ces variants une situation qui était
dans un équilibre fragile et
déséquilibrée par l'arrivée d'un varions
ayant une capacité de transmission
beaucoup plus élevé que le variant que
le virus ancestrale de invariants sud
africain qui est déjà en place comme je
voulais 10 à plus petit niveau de 1 2%
mais qui va évidemment ces temps par
ailleurs donc c'est une vraie question
donc que peut-on faire entre guillemets
et quelle décision qui n'a évidemment
pas du comité scientifique mais qui sont
des décisions politiques je suis bien
clair là dessus
l'édifice n'est là que pour éclairer et
donné les enjeux hobereau pouvoir
politique alors un point par mais qui
est vraiment une question très
importante à mes yeux c'est l'outre-mer
la france en effet à des relations vous
le savez avec à la fois des départements
de avec la guyane d'une part qui est
très proche
finalement dans une vision de la région
de manaus a fait l'effort et la
frontière n'existe pas il ya toujours eu
du passage on le sait donc dans les deux
sens
normalement cette région guyane qui a
fait l'objet d'une vague très importante
l'été et qui était un peu protégés entre
guillemets par l'inversion de la saison
puisque ce virus est relativement
sensible dans ses relations avec le
climat là va se trouver avec une
pénétration de viril ceux du variant du
brésilien qui est en train de se faire
et il est il
joie à de penser qu'on va pouvoir
l'arrêter qui connaît la guyane c'est
qu'on ne pourra pas l'arrêter il va
passer dans notre territoire de guyane
même chose du côté de l'océan indien ou
celui réussi d'africains est déjà très
remontés montre très vite le long de la
côte est de l'afrique au mozambique 1 où
il ya oui oui et on nous avons eu des
reins ou de cas importés du mozambique
eu récemment en france
et puis surtout il ya des liens
importants avec la réunion et mayotte et
mayotte est dans une situation sanitaire
de fonds indépendamment du coc vide qui
est déjà extrêmement difficile de vous
le savez pour de multiples raisons et
qui la va-vite et probablement avec un
variant sud africain qui a trait qui a
déjà très largement très très largement
pénétré alors mayotte est une population
très jeune donc là la conséquence sur la
population mayotte en général sera
relativement faible en termes de sueur
sur les conséquences en terme d'entrées
sur lesquels que les des rallyes nation
qu'ils ont glace finalisation sauf que
évidemment c'est une situation avec un
virus qui se transmet beaucoup qui va
quand même à être extrêmement tendue
dans les semaines qui viennent
la réunion qui est un autre modèle les
premières données que nous avons
montrent que le virus il africain est
déjà de l'ordre de 5 à 6%
donc voilà je termine là dessus pour
vous indiquer que donc à nos yeux
l'arrivée de ces variants pour toute une
série de questions d'ordre scientifique
de fond et de philosophie une fois de
plus de la relation entre virus
autre réponse immunitaire delà de la
sensibilité au vaccin est en train de
modifier la donne
certains ont parlé d'une épidémie dans
l'épidémie d'autres bulles une deuxième
pandémie moi je crois que c'est
l'histoire naturelle en fait est qu'on
va avoir des variants d'épargnants qui
vaille à la barre dont 30 au creusot les
des outils de surveillance adaptée pour
le faire et ce et se donner en termes de
vaccination une très grande souplesse
très grande souplesse sur la
construction des vaccins et surtout bien
pensé qu' il faut qu'on maintienne en
termes de vaccins et jeu
sinon c'est j'avais écouté alain fischer
et je ne vais pas rentrer je dirais on
est très en face on se voit très souvent
dopé chaussons sont très clair qu'il ya
aucune aucune équivoque à cet égard mais
ça montre bien ses sensibilités
un peu diminué à certains vaccins pour
certains de ces variants l'importance de
conserver une réponse immunologique
parfaitement forte et adapté et donc de
respecter les règles sur la vaccination
merci beaucoup pour cette introduction
avant de passer la parole au rapporteur
je vais rappeler pour celles et ceux qui
nous suivent qu'il ya possibilité aussi
de poser des questions sur la plateforme
mise à disposition par l'assemblée
nationale à partir de la page web de
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
partira pas jouable de l'opex tu vous
retrouver à la une la fiche de 7-2 cette
audition et vous pouvez suivre le lien
qui est indiquée pour poser vos
questions il ya déjà un certain nombre
de questions en ligne
je vais donner la parole aux députés
jean françois illy à où l'un des
rapporteurs j'ai commencé par les
rapporteurs
merci monsieur le président mon cher que
avec mon cher jean-françois merci d'être
là c'est vraiment très important et très
intéressant de de pouvoir discuter avec
vous alors vous savez que le texte a une
mission j'irai constitutionnel dans la
mesure où on est là comme parlementaire
pour évaluer le et contrôler des
politiques publiques et d'action du
gouvernement et c'est donc dans cette
action là que dans ce cadre là que nous
citions et donc je vais vous poser deux
séries de questions de deux types de
questions la première deux premiers
types c'est concerne la partie de la
médicale et scientifique
il ya des variants ou avait bien
expliqué c'est très clair il ya le
vaccin c'est également près clair et evo
les explications sur la relation hot hot
microbes ou audi russe est évidemment
l'importance de l'immunité antiviral
vous l'avez clairement également énoncé
moi j'ai une question qui concerne
justement le risque d'échappement liée à
la pression de sélection exercée sur le
virus et on n'est pas étonné de ça et
vous avez bien expliquer également qui
pourrait être et je voudrais en votre
avis là-dessus qui pourrait être due la
conséquence des mesures que nous prenons
actuellement des mesures sanitaires que
nous prenons ces mesures sanitaires
pourquoi j ça c'est parce que ces
mesures sanitaires sont plus ou moins
efficaces mais on a vu quand même leur
efficacité cet été avant le rebond pour
diminuer d'épidémie de la touche
ancestrales les vaccins également arrive
et est ce que c'est une question
scientifique est ce que ça ne le fait
pas le lit quelque part de l'émergence
d'un certain nombre de variants avec les
conséquences que cela pourrait avoir
qui serait pas forcément dirigée contre
la population des personnes âgées mais
plutôt dans le dans ce cadre là vers la
population plus jeune avec des
conséquences qui ne serait pas forcément
pathologique mais qui serait paralysante
pour la société et également avec un
risque plus il ya d'infection plus il ya
de risque de formes graves
c'est la première question est ce que
l'émergence de nouveaux variants la
pression de sélection est garé sur le
virus n'est pas favorisé facilitée par
les mesures que nous prenons et on est
obligé de les prendre y compris y
compris bien entendu la vaccination et
les conséquences que cela peut avoir en
termes de conséquences bien entendu on
est on a parlé du séquençage des
capacités de séquençage nous on sait
tous que le séquençage n'est pas une
technique de routine pour faire du
diagnostic particulier devient une cible
biologique donc quid des kits qui
permettraient non non pas d'avoir une
suspicion de l'apparition de nouveaux
variants mais être plutôt en veille pour
dessiner d'emblée des kits qui pourrait
faire le diagnostic comme ça c'est fait
pour les chiens village deux hectares
pour voir les différentes souches afin
d'être plus peut être précis dans les
statistiques et être plus en amont d'une
réponse
sanitaires ou dira petit qu vis-à-vis de
c2c de ces nouvelles souches de ces
variants on peut multiplier les
plateformes de séquençage bien entendu
mais jamais on arrivera à la souplesse
que l'on a avec des kits que l'on peut
faire pratiquement chez soi et qui nous
permettrait d'avoir une vision beaucoup
plus précise de la dissémination de ces
virus
de la même façon et ton assez agile vous
l'avez peut-être évoquez dans votre dans
vos derniers propos et ton assez agile
sur la préparation permettant
d'anticiper l'arrivée de nouveaux
vaccins qui serait plus adapté sachant
que les variances ont connu leur
séquence est connue et que notamment
avec des virus avec à partir des arn
synthétique gérer il est facile de
synthétiser des vaccins après faut-il
encore qu'il soit efficace et c'est avec
ça mais en tout cas est-ce qu'on est
dense est dans cette situation là ça
c'était la première série de questions
scientifiques qui sont toutes reliées la
deuxième question concerne les relations
que le conseil scientifique et que vous
avez personnellement avec l'exigé et ça
on n'est plus dans le dans notre mission
de contrôle et d'évaluation dans la
mesure où effectivement plus on se
rapproche du corps médical et je sais de
quoi je parle plus on est inquiet plus
on est en alerte plus bas et la relation
est parfois peut être un peu compliqué
parce que pas parce que les politiques
ne comprennent pas à la science vous
comprenez rien à la science mais parce
qu'ils ont d'autres contraintes
et comment se fait cette relation alors
pas personnelle parce qu'on n'a pas
forcément ça m'intéresse pas de savoir
si vous entendez bon mix est pas la
question mais quel est votre puissance
d'impact si je peux dire en tant qu' en
tant que le conseil scientifique et vous
en tant que président de ce conseil
scientifique
je vous remercie merci beaucoup chers
collègues en quoi semblait un coup sénat
la parole la sénatrice sonia de la
provôté oui professeur merci beaucoup
voilà de votre de vos propos liminaire
qui ont amené déjà beaucoup
d'informations
moi j'ai deux questions la première est
celle d'une montée en puissance dont la
populaire d'une acceptabilité moins
bonne en matière de confinement et de
mesures annoncées qui sont clairement
mal vécu on voit ça et là des formes de
révolte et c'est tant le poids
finalement de l'impact social sociétal
et économique de ce qu'on vit depuis un
an et pèse sur les personnes et du coup
a tendance à amoindrir la prise de
conscience du risque sanitaire et moi ce
que j'aimerais savoir c'est comment
comment vous voyez la façon de
communiquer parce que effectivement où
vous l'avez dit très bien on est dans
une situation certes pas encore à la cne
à l'acmé mais c'est le moment où il faut
agir en amont et comment voyez-vous une
communication simple intelligible et qui
pour convaincre nos concitoyens
d'affronter à nouveau des mesures de
restriction et un confinement et si je
dis ça c'est parce que par exemple le
couvre-feu à 18 heures çà et là on
entend des doutes sur son efficacité est
finalement un certain nombre de mesures
qui ont été prises montrent que ça
contribue à moindre accès acceptabilité
de la population et donc sur les
variants en réalité est ce qui lui est
ce qu'il ne faudrait pas avoir un
discours aussi clair que celui que vous
venez d'avoir mais aussi peut-être un
seul canal de communication parce que
les interventions d'un certain nombre un
interlocuteur institutionnel noms font
que le doute s'installe et je pense que
l'acceptabilité va être très difficile
or en l'état actuel des choses le
confinement est la seule mesure qu'on a
trouvée pour diminuer la circulation
virale
on n'a pas atteint le taux d'immunité en
population nécessaire pour pouvoir
diminuer cette circulation et donc
j'aime pas avoir votre point de vue sur
les voies et moyens pour que cette
prochaine mesure qui va arriver puisse
être accepté et quels sont pour vous les
arguments clés sur lesquels il faut
absolument s'appuyer pour pouvoir
convaincre tout le monde de cette
nouvelle mesure
moi je voudrais aussi posé une question
sur sur le séquençage dans le séquençage
donc on est on est vraiment très axé sur
le variant britannique uk
comme dit on sait qu'il y a les autres
variant leurs taux de pénétration en
france n'est pas du tout de la même
importance
mais en réalité n'en sommes pas du tout
aux ex ante et et le variant suis très
sud africain pourrait très bien
apparaître avec sa puissance même
supérieur de diffusion par rapport aux
variants et britanniques
comment dans l'organisation du
séquençage nationale on est en capacité
proprement d'avoir un état des lieux de
l'arrivée de ces variants et et pensez
vous puisqu'on voit quand même qu'à une
régionalisation même en angleterre il ya
une régionalisation
ne pensez-vous pas que dans ces mesures
que nous devrions prendre prendre en
compte et mettre en place comme les
mesures de continuant ne pensez pas que
ne pensez vous pas que la
régionalisation ou la
départementalisation main forte en tout
cas la territorialisation de certaines
mesures pour être une façon efficace
pour pouvoir
confiné en quelque sorte ses variantes
dans un secteur dans lesquels on
pourrait si ce n'est des etam en tout
cas diminuer largement leur diffusion à
l'échelle du pays
je remercie merci chers collègues la
parole au député gérard le seul
rapporteur lui également
merci président merci professeur de du
temps que vous consacrez j'aurai trois
rapide question à vous poser
vous ne l'avez dit nous en sommes tous
convaincus les vaccins constituent l'
espoir majeur pour limiter l'impact de
voir pour résoudre en grande partie la
pandémie de la copie de 19 mais vous
nous avez un petit peu inquiété tout à
l'heure en disant que finalement ce qui
avait été initialement prévu c'est à
dire une sortie à l'automne 2021 et est
repoussé pensez vous que dans ce
contexte le fait d'avoir pour le moment
vacciner un million de français nous
mais globalement dans les clous c'est à
dire est ce que nous sommes dans les
temps pour permettre de diminuer les
pics d'hospitalisation comme vous
l'indiquiez dans votre avis du et du 12
janvier dernier
deuxième question toujours dans votre
avis du 12 janvier qui était très
intéressant dans l'époque les d'ailleurs
que vous avez résumé vous indiquez et je
rejoindrai ma collègue sonia de la
provôté qui vous a interpellé tout à
l'heure sur le sujet vous indiquez que
plus les décisions sont prises
rapidement plus elles sont efficaces et
plus elles permettent d'éviter des
mesures de restrictions sanitaires plus
dur dans un second temps et dans une
certaine mesure vous faisiez des
propositions qu'en est il aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on n'est pas en train de trop
temporiser est ce qu'il y à des mesures
d'urgence à prendre
rapidement et puis troisième question
qui remonte beaucoup en tout cas dans ma
circonscription sur les réseaux sociaux
je vais rencontrer aussi des collectifs
de médecins que pense le conseil
scientifique que pensez-vous de la
recommandation de l'académie de médecine
concernant de supplémenter
préventivement toutes les personnes
carencées en vitamine t
je vous remercie par avance merci
beaucoup chers collègues la parole à la
sénatrice florence lassarade la cie et
président merci professeur de nous j'ai
écouté votre interview sur bfm tv je
crois que c'était mardi matin vous étiez
extrêmement alarmiste visualise la
population pour apparemment préparé un
confinement rapide second film en fait
on l'attend toujours le couvre-feu paris
plus ou moins efficaces plus ou moins
respecté
c'est vrai que quand on est médecin on
se pose également d'autres questions
assez simple vis-à-vis de deux
extrémités de la vie moi je suis
pédiatre à vous savez donc je pense que
les parents sont inquiets de savoir ce
qu'on va faire de nos enfants des colas
vous n'avez pas parlé de la diffusion
pédiatrique de ses variantes
on a dit que les enfants seraient
vraisemblablement plus contagieux avec
scénario là est ce que c'est parce qu'on
disait d est ce que c'est parce qu'on
disait en mars 2000 va on avait envisagé
de fermer les classes et d'ailleurs les
enfants étaient complètement qu'en chine
et parce qu'on les pensait très content
à gsk nouveau c'est pas c'est pas le
sujet finalement parce que depuis qu'il
porte le masque à l'école ils sentent
qu'ils se comptaient beaucoup plus dans
leur famille et c'est ce que ce que dit
la société française de pédiatrie qui
recommence surtout de ne pas confiner
les enfants qui ont des problèmes
du coup assez psychologique assez assez
important on sait que les étudiants
souffrent également terriblement de la
situation depuis un an
j'en viens à la santé mentale finalement
de toute la population
est ce que est ce que on peut considérer
que ce couvre feu suivi deux d'un
confinement probable l'envoi ce que ça
peut générer à l'avancé ce qui vaudrait
pas mieux dire bon allez on y va on
confine en bons coups qu'est-ce qu'est
ce qu'elle est votre influence sur les
décisions du gouvernement à ce sujet
ensuite on a parlé galles ou d'un chèque
au psy sur les étudiants je passe ici là
le remède est à la hauteur de
dégradations psychologique comme un
canal constaté et dernière chose moi qui
m'inquiètent beaucoup parce que j'ai la
ccas dans ma dans ma commune on a fait
une enquête savoir quelles personnes de
plus de 75 ans en amener au centre de
vaccination d'ailleurs très proche à
quelques kilomètres si tenté qu'un jour
on est les vaccins arrivent jusque là il
ya énormément de refus de vaccination
chez cette tranche de population
peut-être parce que je suis anglais
l'aquitaine qui a été peu touché par
l'épidémie mais néanmoins c'est très
très très alarmant quand on sait que le
pays compte y est est à l'arrêt parce
que on craint pour nos aînés une arrivée
en réanimation
moi je me demande s'il n'aurait pas
fallu préconisé une obligation vaccinale
comme on l'a fait pour les pour les
jeunes enfants
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas dû préconisé
une obligation vaccinale pour cette
tranche de population j'ai peur qu'on se
heurte une fois que les vaccins seront à
ce sujet et dernière question alors plus
de technique il semblerait quand même
que le kaiser dû à une plaie qu'est le
modern art puisse s'adapter aux variants
et soit pas si inefficace que ça sur le
futur logo sur les variants quand les
petits par contre des vaccins base d'adn
au virus
astrazeneca d'autres d'autres vaccins
puits traditionnels je ne parle pas de
notre abandonné c'est ça m'amène à poser
la question également de la fierté
française sur le sur ses capacités à
produire un vaccin sur mercier merci
beaucoup merci chers collègues ça fait
beaucoup de questions j'ajouterai deux
questions très brève dans ce dans ce
premier tour professeur vous nous
évoquer évidemment il ya aussi des
aspects on l'a vu dans certaines des
questions d esprit qui relève des
sciences humaines et sociales des
questions psychologiques ce que vous
pouvez nous rappeler qu'elle est là par
rapport au conseil scientifique dans son
fonctionnement quelles sont les
compétences que vous avez en interne les
différentes spécialités quelles sont
celles sur lesquelles vous allez
chercher des avis ailleurs calé lequel
le mode de fonctionnement du conseil
avec la communauté scientifique
et puis j'ai une deuxième question vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure dans votre
propos de en gros trois vagues
je me souviens d'une audition dans
laquelle avec un épidémiologiste dans
lequel on expliquer bien que en vrai on
avait commencé à perdre le contrôle de
l'épidémie en juillet ou en août en tout
cas très tôt et que c'est jamais revenu
on a vu aussi que dans le deuxième
confinement n'est jamais redescendu en
dessous des seuils qu'on avait
prédéfinis pour comme étant le retour à
la normale globalement qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire avec du recul sur l'ensemble
de la dynamique depuis depuis mars c'est
pas c'est pas vraiment trois vagues
c'est pas non plus un seul événement
qu'est ce qu'on quels enseignements on
tire de tout ça voilà pour ce sens
semble ça fait beaucoup de questions et
on aura un deuxième tour de questions
après encore beaucoup de questions
correspondant à un sujet extrêmement
chargé bien sûr à vous la parole
professeurs tout d'abord le conseil
scientifique qui sommes-nous comment
fonctionne en nous et finalement quelles
sont nos relations avec eux avec les
autorités sanitaires de ce pays
alors on est 12 le conseil scientifique
s'est il formé 10 mars à la suite d'une
réunion de scientifiques qui avait lieu
à l'elysée
quelques jours précisément le conseil
scientifique a été a été formé avec des
propositions que j'ai pu faire des
propositions qu'a fait le ministre de la
santé puis nous sommes tombés d'accord
sur un certain nombre de noms je l'avais
souhaité multidisciplinaire il comprend
en particulier bien sûr virologues
animateurs infectiologues modélisateurs
épidémiologistes mais aussi un médecin
généraliste qui avait qui est impliqué
dans le collège de l'ach s
j'avais souhaité également qui est des
scientifiques des sciences humaines et
sociales et nous avons une anthropologue
spécialiste des maladies émergentes et
chercheurs du cnrs professeur dé des
politiques publiques à sciences po
nous avons une représentation de la
société civile pas suffisante à mes yeux
mais néanmoins présentes qui a
d'ailleurs été nommé au niveau du du
sénat avec la présidente de
l'association addes été carbon dans des
sujets en grande précarité car on
rappelle que cette pandémie
comme toutes les grandes pandémies
touche évidemment est pleinement injuste
et touche bien sûr les populations les
plus fragiles et pas seulement liés à
l'ajout ou à des conditions physiques
mais aussi à les conditions de précarité
nous fonctionnons eux on s'est réunis
trois fois par jour pendant les trois
premiers mois et on fonctionne chaque
chaque scientifique et un peu tête de
punch comme je l'indiquais tout à
l'heure de sa communauté
il a cherché un certain nombre d'idées
au sein de sa communauté
et puis on les fait remonter on saute
saisi engoncé autosaisie de environ
trois quarts des des sujets et c'est
seulement un quart de saisine que nous
avons eu de la part des autorités
sanitaires
dernier point peut-être sur le sur le
mode de fonctionnement gelé souhaité que
les avis du conseil scientifique soit
publique
je rappelle que par exemple est
l'équivalent du conseil scientifique
comblés ils étaient anonymes départ ils
sont pas restés longtemps parce qu'ils
ont c'est vite
sorti huit ans après ce mais n'avait pas
d'avis écrit moi j'ai souhaité que
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens
les amis puissent être écrit que la
presse qui se les avoirs que les
différentes autorités mais c'est d'abord
il ya un délai c'est à dire qu'on les
donne d'abord aux autorités sanitaires
et gouvernementales et puis ensuite il
ya des liens souvent de quelques jours
et entre temps il peut y avoir des
décisions de politiques qui ont été
prises en s'appuyant sur ses amis alors
que la vie sort légèrement après sur la
question posée toujours de relations du
conseil scientifique avec l'exécutif
bon je crois que c'est extrêmement clair
le conseil scientifique est là pour
éclairer l'exécutif il n'est pas là pour
décider de quoi que ce soit les
décisions sont des décisions et mais
éminemment politique et elles sont
prises par les politiques le le conseil
scientifique met sur la table un certain
nombre de points qui lui paraissent de
point de situation d'enjeux qui lui
paraissent importants 2 points deux
points difficiles de points clés
éventuellement c'est là où c'est
probablement le plus difficile à
comprendre pour la population on
s'appuie en effet sur on a une vision je
dirais nous sommes déjà pour vous pour
vous donner un ordre d'idée nous nous
sommes en train de réfléchir là
maintenant sur le post ce qui sera je ne
sais pas quoi
que décidera le politique au plus haut
niveau c'est comment on sort d'une
situation aussi difficile que celle là
ça y est donc on essaye en permanence
d'anticiper un peu les questions qu'ils
veulent qu'ils peuvent se poser les
relations donc avec nos politiques nous
suit ou ne le suis pas ce sont des
décisions politiques c'est à lui de les
prendre
je constate que dans beaucoup de cas il
nous a suivis et puis on a quelques
cache pas autant donner deux trois
exemples où il ne nous a pas suivis ou
par exemple sur l'école au mois deux
mois de mai et où finalement l'exécutif
a souhaité réouvrir les écoles nous le
souhaitions l'école et les conserver
fermée jusqu'au mois de juillet et il a
eu raison
après a posteriori me demander l'avis
que la vision que j'avais il y a eu
raison c'était parce que il ya
évidemment une vision sanitaire mais il
ya une vision sociétale et il ya une
vision économique et qui est en jeu que
nous avons aussi en est pas complètement
borné dans dans des travers sanitaires
deuxièmement
éléments réclamés à que la constitution
d'un comité citoyen de liaison citoyenne
de discussions avec la société pour
faire remonter un certain nombre de
points pour des raisons diverses et des
autorités ne l'ont pas mis en place
elles l'ont mis en place le mieux vaut
tard que jamais avec autour du vaccin et
du cse vous le savez depuis quelques
temps enfin dernier point et c'est
peut-être là le point le plus sensible
c'est dans des situations difficiles on
sent bien que il y à une évolution que
la situation est un point est un point
clé un peu critique qui peut se poser
c'est une situation qu'on a eu au mois
de septembre nous avons nous avons
souligné l'importance de la reprise de
l'épidémie et l'arrivée d'une deuxième
vague entre guillemets avec les nuances
qu'on pourrait y apporter et où il ya eu
il ya parfois un décalage entre le
signal donné par le conseil scientifique
et la décision politique
mais ce sont des décisions une fois de
plus très complexe on est également dans
cette période là où on a donné des
signaux et bien sûr la décision
politique sera prise je dirais donc je
ne sais pas comment d'ailleurs c'est une
décision qui sera prise par le politique
jeu sur ce dernier point la situation
actuelle je vous ai donné la situation
épidémiologique en france
je considère qu'on est donc dans ce
quelque chose d'urgent jambes et je ne
retire pas les paroles sur l'idée que
plus empreinte décision beat plus
ensuite lé lé lé je dirais line est une
activité qui est importante
ne confondons pas l'urgence et l'extrême
urgence sur des décisions aussi complexe
que re confiné un pays quelles que
soient la ou rouen tout cas poursuivre
un couvre-feu
quelle que soit la décision qui sera
prise par la politique c'est ça mérite
que les enjeux on le voit bien et vos
questions le montre bien que les enjeux
sanitaires sont évidemment les enjeux
importants mais ils ne sont pas les
seuls et sans enjeux sociétaux et songer
d'acceptabilité des mesures les enjeux
de conséquences pour notre jeunesse
croyait que le comité scientifique
je suis moi-même grand-père un gg j'ai
enfin on a on est on est des citoyens
comme les autres et on se rendent
parfaitement compte des enjeux extra
sanitaire qui peuvent être existé et
donc de la difficulté des décisions donc
bien sûr
on est dans une moment où il va falloir
prendre des décisions est ce que ces
décisions étaient depuis le début de la
semaine à un jour près comme je l'entend
partout
la réponse est donc prenons le temps
d'essayer de construire de façon
intelligente la moins mauvaise des
réponses pour construire autour de cela
donc voilà sur les relations entre le
comité scientifique et son mode de
fonctionnement il politique
après de très très nombreuses questions
un surhomme les diagnostics les kits de
séquençage etc
oui il faut pas non plus qu'il faut à la
fois une stratégie de kits de pca des
gnostiques vous avez parfaitement raison
et puis à côté du séquençage mais il
faut pas non plus penser que tout va
résoudre que les séquençages va tout
réseau les qui diagnostique pour
l'instant sont construits avec des psr
qui donne des signes d' alerte mais qui
ne donne pas des signaux positifs en
disant c'est tel ou tel type de variants
cela dit cpcr je dirais qu'il
permettrait de discriminer de dire
immédiatement si c'est un barrier
anglais ou invariants sud africain nous
allons les avoir dans les jours ou dans
les semaines qui viennent
elles sont déjà construites par les
laboratoires de virologie à l'ap-hp et
elles vont être elles vont être
disponibles donc c'est exactement la
réponse à la question que vous posez par
ailleurs le séquençage oui il est
important mais en moins parce qu'il
permet une surveillance non après sans a
priori c'est à dire si en séquences on
est capable de voir arriver à nous
varions c'est ce qu'ont vu les anglais
d'ailleurs qui n'était pas connu la
technique de pcr quart mais seulement
finalement d'avoir une surveillance
diagnostic d'invariants qu'on connaît
déjà et dont on connaît les mutations
c'est donc n'opposons pas les la
stratégie de technique de pcr monter
avec eux santé publique france
l'ensemble des laboratoires de virologie
et et soyons un peu positif une fois de
plus la france est probablement le seul
pays d'europe qui est capable de sortir
en ce moment des chiffres assez précis
sur l'arrivée des variants un je vous ai
donné quelques chiffres au portugal par
exemple et en angleterre bien sûr mais
l'allemagne là aussi exactement la
pénétration de ces virus en allemagne
n'a pas le modèle de suivi et de
dépistage de séquençage que nous avons
mis en place
elle va l'avoir pression sur balles
zouk nous hein mais c'est pour dire
qu'on est aussi réactif sur un certain
nombre sur un certain nombre de sujets
l'agilité sur sur les variants et la
stratégie vaccinale
oui alors là les gens rentrent dans
l'aide dans la région a été l'axé donc
je pourrais être bien clair je rappelle
que les deux vaccins à mairena
finalement couvre et permettent
d'induire une réponse immunitaire qui
permet de neutraliser le variant anglais
c'est comme ça le point essentiel là je
dirai à tous partager ce soir et puis si
en effet il ya des pénétrations d'autres
maria les deux les techniques de vaccins
mais reina permettent d'anticiper cela
alors il ya il ya deux questions qui
sont sur la table autour de ces vaccins
et de l'arrivée et éventuellement de
variants premièrement il savait qu'on ne
connaît pas la durée exacte protection
de réponse immunitaire induite par ces
vagues l'est de l'inde 8 par ces vaccins
pour les cimes de quelques mois après on
sait pas trop et il ya déjà une
stratégie menée par par ces compagnies
et avec les scientifiques d'ailleurs de
se dire on pourrait rebooster la réponse
immunitaire avec eux un nouveau une
nouvelle vaccination nouvelle
vaccination
je dirais dirigé classiques comme été le
variant initiale ou bien qu'entre à
nouveau variant qui serait capable c'est
à dire qu'une population qui aurait été
vaccinées pourraient être vaccinés au
bout de neuf mois par exemple
ils sont en train de tester ça avec un
vaccin directement dédiés vis-à-vis de
telle ou telle variant et puis ils vont
plus loin et en discuter tout à l'heure
avec le avec eux à la fischer et émail
paul kelly avec le le patron de deux
moderna kiwi ils comptent ils sont en
train de construire la capacité de
vaccins et et possédant plusieurs et
mairena dirigée contre 2 contre
différents variant 1 c'est-à-dire des
vaccins pluri variant ils sont même en
train d'essayer de de construire des
vaccins qui permettrait à la fois de
couvrir la grippe et le corps un navire
issement
est-ce qu'ils vont y arriver pour une
interrogation la technique en tout cas
le permet et ils ont déjà des ils ont
déjà un certain nombre de données
puisque des vaccins contenant plusieurs
m et rena sont actuellement disponibles
contre le cytomégalovirus et c'est elle
c'était le vaccin sur le calice était
plongée avant d'arriver sur le corps
d'art maderna et ils ont déjà donc la
capri savent qu'on peut en plus petite
quantité et non pas au total avec les
quantités initiales du vaccin parce que
sinon ça ferait trop gros sur la
quantité de là mais reina mais deux en
plus petite quantité on peut construire
un vaccin
je dirais plus riches potentiels est
dirigé contre différents variant qui
pourrait donc s'adapter au fur et à
mesure il faut souhaiter g que donc je
dirais la pression vaccinale et c'est
dans cette balance entre la sélection
des variants et la pression vaccinale il
faut souhaiter que la pression vaccinale
pour ça qu'il faut vacciner vite et le
plus de personnes et bien le permettre
le de ne pas non plus multiplier je
dirais la construction de vaccins plus
arrive à rien parce que si on est en
permanence en train de courir derrière
ça sera ça sera pas une bonne chose
alors deuxième type de questions c'est
finalement le l'acceptabilité et là et
la crise
je dirais un peu sociétal un autour de
de cette crise
je comprends parfaitement votre question
le conseil scientifique de la comprends
parfaitement
si ça vous rassure tout le monde en a
assez j'en ai assez moi aussi mais moi
ça n'a pas d'importance mais à plus
jeune qui est un jeune étudiant qui est
en première année qui n'a jamais vu
qu'il n'a jamais vu ses potes à plus
jeunes qui n'arrivent pas à trouver de
boulot un plus jeunes qui n'arrivent pas
à trouver de petites amies le conseil
scientifique sur sa dimension humaine et
sociale en a pleinement conscience et
c'est un enjeu commun que nous
construisons la balance en train tout
sanitaires tout sanitaire c'est à dire
c'est le choix qui a été fait jusqu'à
maintenant de protéger les personnes les
plus fragiles et plus anciennes et des
diminuer la morbidité mortalité par
rapport à une vision qui à la fois et
c'est de tenir le sanitaire parce que je
ne crois pas que les français ça je
m'avance à titre personnel mais envie
d'avoir des images difficiles eu trop de
décès parce que c'est une vision de la
société qui est que nous avons tous et
qui est complexe mais et versements qui
permet aussi et de d'avoir une france
qui vit et je comprends tout à fait ce
n'est pas au conseil scientifique de se
prononcer là dessus
ce sont des sillons évidemment politique
je le dis néanmoins si vous voulez me
poussée dans mes retranchements
je pense que nous sommes véritablement
avec une question un peu sociétale et
éthiques
quasi éthiques actuellement de
finalement de politique générationnel
entre continuer à préserver la santé des
plus anciens mais peut-être au détriment
de la santé des plus jeunes
et c'est une vraie grandes questions
auxquelles nous sommes très sensibles
alors la communication c'est un élément
fondamental
le conseil scientifique n'est pas là ce
n'est pas il n'est pas là pour
communiquer je vous rappelle qu'on est
on communique à l'occasion de la sortie
de nos avis pour être explicatif
j'essaie parfois de le prendre la parole
mais vous avez qu pas tellement souvent
même si même si les prises de parole
sont se sont parfois surdimensionnés par
les médias pour expliquer et je
comprends parfaitement votre expliqué
des sujets difficiles expliqué ce que
vous disiez c'est à dire finalement pour
le français qui est beaucoup plus
intelligent qu'on le pense bien sûr à
chaque fois qu'est ce que ça veut dire
avoir rien c'est un risque théorique on
lui raconte qu'on va être qu'on va se
trouver avec beaucoup plus une pression
sur les sur les services de réanimation
mi mars et que c'était un me vois rien
il voit la france qui continue l'a1 donc
c'est extrêmement compliqué d'expliquer
comment l'arrivée d'un variant en effet
il faut avoir une attitude préventive
pour essayer d'éviter d'avoir trop de
retentissement sur le système de soins
est trop d'entrée en rénovation et de
décès dans la période de la fin mars par
exemple la communication et la base de
la confiance la confiance vous le savez
c'est un phénomène fondamental dans les
crises quel que soit le type de crise
c'est la confiance ce n est pas là
d'emblée elle se construit et on passe
par et au débat et je j'ai pleinement
quand j'ai pleinement conscience que de
la même façon qu'il ya parfois de des
problèmes de confiance entre le citoyen
et politique
il ya aussi il y a aussi des problèmes
de confiance entre le citoyen et les
scientifiques mais c'est un autre débat
que ce soir et qui tu devrais leçons à
tirer me semble-t-il de la crise de la
crise que vit alors le séquençage je
vous en ai déjà parlé ensuite l'espoir
avec les vaccins
oui oui les les vaccins restent les
soirs c'est fondamental ce que j'ai
voulu introduire c'est qu'on avait un un
schéma assez simple en début d'année
avec une sortie de crise pour la
mi-octobre
enfin pour la pour le mois d'octobre on
sent bien que ces voix là on s'interroge
sur la finale ment la survenue
éventuellement d'un autre variant qui
pourrait qu'il pourrait reposer une
question on s'interroge sur la
durabilité des vaccins mais aussi sur
les réponses que je vous ai dit la
capacité aussi l'algérie mène qui va
être capable de fabriquer de nouveaux
vaccins
on s'interroge également sur lie sur
finalement refaire rentrer dans une
sorte de vaccination chronique modifié
qu on modifierait chaque année vis-à-vis
de de ce virus
on est je dirais il faut être très
prudent il faut être très modeste
vis-à-vis de ce virus
vraiment très malade je le dis on peut
vraiment toute franchise je on a je
pense me semble-t-il une sortie de crise
possible quand on aura vacciner
l'immense majorité des personnes qui
sont les plus à risque et toutes ne
seront pas vaccinés
parce que vous l'avez très bien dit il
ya des gens qui vont mais très peu de
gens qui vont refuser la montée à - yeux
1dans dans cette population
il ya des gens qui sait qu'il y aura une
réponse immunitaire qui sera moins bonne
et si vous prenez 80 % des 80 % de
réponses lui il faut 8 64 vous avez
quand même un tiers de cette population
qui du coup ne serait pas protégé donc
vous voyez que il faut à la fois mettre
beaucoup de choses dans les vaccins
mais penser à autre chose que les
vaccins et probablement les mois qui
viennent vont être un élément très
important
pour autre chose que pour les vaccins
ils vont être sur la thérapeutique et
sur la thérapeutique de prise en charge
des personnes les plus à risque et d'un
traitement immédiat dès qu'on a un
traitement possible
alors est-ce qu'on est suffisamment non
les vaccins je nous ai répondu chez les
sujets âgés les enfants oui les écoles
oui c'est un sujet évidemment qui est à
la fois très je dirais très technique et
très sociétale les données anglaise qui
initialement suggéré que le variant
anglais était plus transmissible au sein
des écoles et des enfants ne nous ont
pas convaincus
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous avez
vu dans nos avis le fait que nous
recommandions y compris avec les
variants la poursuite de l'ouverture des
écoles parce que il ya d'autres gens jeu
et vous avez pleinement conscience
qu'ils sont des enjeux sociétaux et en
particulier pour les enfants qui sont
des délits sud et des classes les plus
fragiles ou ou socialement défavorisés
nous restons pour l'instant sur cette
position c'est à dire que si vous voulez
quand vous avez une circulation de sang
des virus en population générale
on place chiffrés en général sudiste
chiffres au hasard on peut le chiffrer
dans le même temps 60 chez les enfants
c'est à dire un peu plus bas que dans la
population adulte
vous avez très bien dit que chez les
enfants étaient infectés par les adultes
et non l inverse
mais quand vous avez une circulation
virale qui montent à 200 ch et chez les
adultes
eh bien elle monte à 120 chez les
enfants c'est à dire que les enfants
sont aussi un facteur de transmission
mais ils ne sont pas un facteur de
transmission particulièrement je dirais
impliqués dans la transmission de ces
variants donc c'est un enjeu qui
évidemment totalement essentiel est pour
l'instant de restons sur notre position
si je regarde si sébastien au niveau
européen il ya la moitié d'un boîtier la
moitié des pays européens ont choisi de
fermer les écoles
c'est le cas en angleterre par exemple
c'est le cas dans un certain nombre de
pays
puis la moitié d'autres pays européens à
être concernés a décidé de conserver les
écoles
l'affluence des destiny en fin des
préconisations du conseil scientifique
sur les décisions du gouvernement je lui
ai répondu tout à l'heure c'est on
sépare bien ce qu'est le conseil
scientifique qui est là pour pour
présenter un certain nombre d'états des
lieux et et d'éclairage sanitaires et
les décisions sont celles des politiques
on est une grande démocratie
l'idée car un peu germé dans la tête des
journalistes à une période en dix ans il
ya un troisième pouvoir médical en
france
j'oubliais immédiatement c'est archi
faux il ya bien sûr en cas de crise
sanitaire le pouvoir politique en temps
ou n'entend pas ce que dit
éventuellement les conseiller
scientifique au médicaux mais c'est la
même chose donc l'ensemble des pays les
décisions elles sont politiques enfin
sur la notion de vagues que poser
monsieur madani
oui vous avez raison peut-être c'est
peut-être un peu simpliste sa notion de
premières vagues de deuxième vague et
qui serait une troisième vague avec les
variants c'est peut-être enfin on est
tous persuadés que c'est la même
histoire
et puis qu'en fonction des mesures de
contrainte et d2 et de circulation de
changement de l'été qui arrive et
brassage des populations
eh bien on passe par de toute façon les
l'idée n'est pas de contrôler et d'année
et de l'est et 2 d'éradiquer ce virus
vous avez tous compris ça l'idée de le
maintenir à un certain niveau qui
permette et de protéger en tout cas
jusqu'à maintenant c'était ça l'objectif
de protéger en priorité contre la
morbidité et la mortalité
les personnes les plus anciennes et les
plus choisis merci beaucoup
nous allons nous lancer dans un deuxième
round de questions je pense qu'on
s'arrêtera juste a juste à deux salves
et je vais donner la parole au député
loïc prudemment merci monsieur le
président monsieur le professeur
delfraissy
depuis l'origine de la pandémie
l'ensemble discours de lutte contre le
coronavirus reprend cet objectif ainsi
formulé stopper la circulation du virus
après si je m'interroge donc sur le mode
de circulation du virus se déplace-t-il
à pied je fais ce trait d'humour pour
souligner une évidence c'est que les
flux de personnes sont bien sûr le
vecteur de transmission est donc de
diffusion ne fais que vous pourriez
m'expliquer l'absence complète de
stratégie depuis au moins le printemps
dernier du contrôle des flux de
population ce qui percute la stratégie
vaccinale il pourrait enrayer alors que
nous faisons face à cet afflux de
variants aucune obligation d'être testé
pour se déplacer au sein de l'espace
schengen faisant une fine et de l'europe
le foyer épidémique de la deuxième vague
aucune obligation dernier façon aucune
condition de peste pour accéder au
territoire français
au milieu de ce bouillon de culture
européen est et ce depuis le début de la
crise et quasi aucune limite dans les
déplacements inter régionaux en france
en dehors des courtes périodes de
confinement créant notamment cet été
les conditions d'une diffusion large du
virus dans le pays
alors ces derniers jours la cohérence
semblait enfin avoir atteint le sommet
de l'état avec cette annonce une
exigence de test négatif pour rentrer
sur le territoire français hélas
patatras cela ne concerne que les
entrées et via les ports et les
aéroports alors si le virus ne se
déplace pas à pied il le prend
visiblement que les bateaux les avions
ce salon pose question monsieur le
professeur delfraissy pouvait comment
pouvez vous expliquer cette absence
durable d'exigence de test cette absence
de contrôle des flux entrants qui a fait
ses preuves ailleurs sur la planète
absence
comblé alors que les variants se
multiplient à nos frontières
je vous remercie de votre réponse merci
chers collègues la parole à ma collègue
hugues est génial je crois qu'il ya une
question les unes que ce sont les aléas
du direct
c'est bien je suis humain mois
absolument
bonjour cédric merci de me passer la
parole cher professeur delfraissy
je vais plutôt poser une question qui
nous emmènera dans la durée depuis la
l'arrivée du coc vide on apprend à vivre
avec
avec la maladie mais on voit aussi que
on a besoin de concilier la question
économie la question de société et la
question de lutter contre le virus
aujourd'hui avec l'arrivée de l'arrivée
du vaccin
on a des mamours une belle perspective
en tout cas pour éradiquer la maladie
mais on se rend compte aussi que à terme
puisque vous avez bien parler de dick et
leurs variantes qui qu'ils arrivent au
fur et à mesure et on voit aussi qu'au
niveau de la recherche française
on est un peu en tout cas en l'état par
rapport à la découverte des vaccins
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire s'il
s'agit d'une question liée au
financement de la recherche dans le
domaine de la médecine ou est-ce qu'il
s'agit en fait d'un état que la france a
accusé à la fois aux recherches dans les
domaines de de la virologie ou terminés
pensez vous que nous serons en mesure de
rattraper ce retard ou des questions de
souveraineté dans le domaine du médical
à 6 merci chers collègues
est ce qu'il y à d'autres d'autres
questions des parlementaires ici ce
n'est de la provôté vous les instits
d'abord je vais laisser la parole à
michel meunier à la fin je repasserai la
parole à ce n'est pas pressé de
questions sénatrice michel meunier puis
sénateur andré guiol merci bien
une piste vous m'entendez c'est bon mais
une question professeur delfraissy en
tout cas merci d'avoir mis au centre de
votre propos la question d'éthique et de
démocratie sanitaire vous savez que ces
deux sujets qui me sont chers et qui
nous ont valu de nous retrouver au ccn
est-ce que vous avez je vais être direct
1 est-ce que vous avez quand même
l'impression d'être suffisamment entendu
aux conseils scientifiques sur ces
sujets parce que pour être clair vous le
savez comme nous les français s'y
retrouvent pas bien les françaises sont
lassés et c'est de plus en plus
compliqué s'y retrouver même avec vos
propos professeurs puisque vous avez
quand même changé de pied entre fin
décembre et puis janvier sur
le timing est en tout cas quand vous
nous disiez fin jean fin décembre que le
temps était compté que c'était une
course à la montre et que toutes les
semaines comptait on vous tendait et
aujourd'hui donc de manière argumentée
vous dit bon on n'est pas une semaine
près afrique on y comprend plus trop
voilà et donc est ce que vous pensez que
ça pourrait être plus clairement exprimé
aux françaises et aux français
et de quelle manière on pourrait mettre
voilà ces propos sans trop de confusion
j'en ai encore pour preuve dans votre
exposé vous nous avez fait la différence
entre urgence et extrême urgence
donc c'est c'est troublant tout ça je
trouve de me voilà un point de vue de
nos médecins
merci merci donc sénateurs guillaume et
bonsoir
fort heureusement vote positif beaucoup
de malades atteints par ce virus
guérissent pour autant au début de la
pandémie à circuler le bruit que cette
maladie laissé pas mal de ses quais
notamment sur les poumons et j'ai
beaucoup de questions des amis c'est
dans ce sens qu'elle est il exactement
et quels sont les guillemets les landes
langage sans catastrophisme à un
candidat vérité mais tout ce qu'on
appelle parfois covit de longue durée
troisième phase du coc vie dont on a
l'impression que c'était l'un des soucis
majeurs une fois que c'est un souci
reste six rotations et qu'on évoquait au
début de la pandémie mais je dois avouer
que je l'entends pas depuis quelques
temps les autres collègues
parlementaires d'autres questions alors
oui et sonia de la provôté voulait
remettre sur le tapis juste précisé
qu'elle n'avait pas eu une réponse
complète sur certaines de ces questions
oui merci beaucoup en fait j'avais
évoqué la question des mesures telles
qu'elles étaient
proposer le couvre-feu à 18 heures où en
est on sur l'évaluation de son effet les
vous aviez préconisé dans votre rapport
une possible territorialisation des
mesures il ya une régionalisation de
l'épidémie on voit ça en tout cas c'est
l'impression qu'on en a quand on regarde
ce qui s'est passé en angleterre et il
commence à avoir des aspects positifs
mais parce qu'il ya des connu des
conflits finement plus précoce à londres
par exemple et des mesures plus
drastiques dans certains secteurs
est ce que vous pensez pas que cet
élément là peut être un outil utile dans
l'arsenal que nous avons pour lutter
contre la diffusion du virus et est
votre point de vue sur ce qu'on a appelé
le confinement light c'est à dire celui
de la deuxième vague et le confinement
plus dur celui de la première vague est
ce que les deux confinement finalement
ont un effet identique
voilà parce qu'on on a du mal finalement
à voir clair et est ce que ces mesures
là elles sont adossées sur des objectifs
stratégiques précis en matière
d'incidence et en matière d'occupation
des lits hospitaliers
en d'autres termes est-ce qu'on a un
arsenal d'outils de ce type de
restrictions de déplacements de
restriction du quotidien en fonction de
l'évolution de la maladie et avec lequel
on pourrait qu'on pourrait utiliser au
fur et à mesure de l'évolution des
chiffres des biologies merci beaucoup je
vais pas d'autres questions des
parlementaires je vais relayer comme
promis des questions posées sur la
plateforme il y en a beaucoup en
parrainant une bonne cinquantaine qui
n'est pas tout les reprendre mais je
vais essayer de faire une synthèse de
certains des sujets qui reviennent le
plus et vous demandez professeurs des
commentaires sur les sur les sujets
suivants une question sur les beaucoup
de questions sur les traitements non
vaccinaux et il y avait une époque où il
y avait tellement de questions et
discussions avec beaucoup de
controverses sur les drogues si
chloroquine les traitements proposés par
didier rahout la question de la
prescription ou pas par les médecins de
ville de ces traitements leur mdv
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui
puis d'autres qui parlent aussi de
retenir zine de 2,2 encore d'autres
comment s'appelle donc encore d'autres
d'autres traitements je n'ai pas pas
noté ici qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui maintenant sur l'arsenal non
vaccinale de traitement de réponse de
réponse à l'épidémie
une question sur la transparence ou est
ce qu'on peut lire vos publications du
conseil scientifique ou est ce qu'on
peut savoir à quelles études vous vous
référez quelqu'un qui veut un citoyen
qui veut savoir le travail et
transparence et savoir à quelles études
et à qui vous vous référez quelle est la
démarche qui doit effectuer sur les
tests fighter moderna et autres est ce
qu'aujourd'hui pour nous garantir que un
serment il y avait une question sur la
fiabilité des études des données
certains ont parlé de fraudes un moment
est ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui là
avec tout ce qu'on sait on a la garantie
que les tests ont été menés avec tout ce
qu'il faut comme rigueur que dire des
autorisations de mises sur le marché sur
les questions de sur d'autres sujets qui
suit des questions de contamination il
ya eu débat à chaque fois sur les
mesures qu'est ce qu'il faut mettre
qu'est-ce qu'il faut que m est ce que on
peut garder transport ouvert fermer les
commerces ou le contraire et c'est
qu'est ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui sur les
endroits et les situations dans
lesquelles se font les contaminations
une question qui est posée que je que je
répercute brut de décoffrage si je puis
dire est ce qu'il conviendrait de
confiner les plus âgés qui sont les
personnes à risque en attendant qu'on
puisse par exemple toutes les clés
vacciner et laisser la population jeune
plus libres pour tenir compte de la des
troubles psychologiques dont on voit
qu'ils atteignent certains certains pans
de la population plus jeune une question
sur la vitamine d
et puis si on a en pratique on voit tous
ces informations qui circulent et etde
communiqué akil médecine sur la vitamine
d qu'est-ce qu'ils font pratiquer ce que
nos concitoyens doivent prendre leurs
vitamines d tous les matins est ce qu'il
s'agit de quelque chose d'autre
est ce qu'il ya un scénario dans lequel
on se retrouverait avec pourquoi pas
un ensemble de mutations vaccination
confinement à répétition pendant
longtemps et qui sait des années est ce
que c'est quelque chose que avec les
conséquences que ça aurait aussi
économique aussi psychologiques et c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut qu'on peut
imaginer
le confinement et toutes ces polémiques
sur est-ce qu'il faut confiné est ce que
certains disent que le ms n'avait pas
une attitude claire sur le confinement
voir le déconseiller qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire aujourd'hui par rapport à la
pratique internationale sur le
confinement en tant que réponse efficace
le complotisme est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui vous affecte est-ce que sur
les réseaux est ce que toutes les
théories qu'on voit passer sans quelque
chose qui affecte la stratégie de
vaccination la stratégie qu'ovide votre
action qui parfois trouble votre message
de au message de conseillers
scientifiques les conflits d'intérêts au
sein du conseil scientifique et ce
qu'ils ont été déclarées expurgé quelle
est votre politique par rapport à cela
vous même est ce que vous êtes vacciné
et au sein du conseil scientifique
qu'est ce que quelle est la position
personnelles des uns et des autres sur
les vaccins voilà écouté il y avait la
question sur la sur le territorie
gestion ainsi pourquoi est ce que les
modèles épidémiologiques sur lesquels
vous basez ne sont pas rendus publics
sur des plateformes telles que
plateforme github plateforme de
développement tels que on puisse l'aider
des scientifiques en herbe puissent les
analyser eux-mêmes et voir sur quoi tout
cela se base
voilà j'ai pas rendu justice à toute la
variété de questions j'en ai adouci ou
expurgé certaines mais ces questions
vous donne une bonne échantillon des
questions que se posent les concitoyens
qui nous écoutent
il ya deux premières grandes questions
autour de la circulation du virus et de
la question aussi où on se contaminent
comment ce conte éviter une question l'a
finalement et le sait-on après presque
un an de pandémie on commence à mieux le
savoir à partir de trois études qui sont
toutes les trois
paru début décembre
vous voyez que c'est relativement récent
une étude américaine
une étude anglaise et une étude
française menée par un loup fontanes et
la cie du pasteur à partir
la déclaration de gens qui se sont été
contaminés qui rentrent dans le modèle
des déclarations de déco vide et qui à
qui on demande s'ils sont volontaires
pour répondre à un certain nombre de
questions par mail et plus qui ensuite
participé à cette enquête
alors ce qui ressort c'est que on se
contaminent lorsqu'on arrête de porter
le masque et qu'on mange et qu'on boit
soit à l'extérieur soit chez soi
ce sont on enlève son masque pour manger
et boire avec des amis de la famille
chez soi des amis à l'extérieur ce sont
les deux modes de contamination les plus
fréquents alors ça veut dire les bars et
des restaurants sont fermés est exact
d'ailleurs et l'épidémie continue on
entend parfois oui puisqu'en effet une
partie de la contamination et en
particulier chez les plus anciens
il faut bien ainsi si c'est encore
terminée il faut bien qu'on se pose des
questions où il se contaminent et la
plupart des anciens font attention
actuellement sauf qu'ils sont pas
suffisamment attention pour se protéger
entre guillemets quand ils sont chez eux
les avis de leurs familles de leurs amis
des personnes qui viennent des voix et
que c'est le deuxième élément de
contamination il ya d'autres évidemment
il ya des repas et chaque fois qu'on
enlève son masque et les des repas
possible dans les restaurants
d'entreprises sont aussi possiblement a
lieu de contamination via une série d'
endroit qui qui par contre
n'apparaissent pas clairement parce que
les gens sont en france gens font très
attention ne citoyens les médias nous
montrent essentiellement les minorités
mais la majorité des gens fait très
attention aux français là
vous le disiez tout à l'heure il ya une
population qui a peur maintenant qui est
inquiète qui mais qui a été finalement
relativement sage jusqu'à maintenant
qu'un cas parfaitement toléré des
mesures extrêmement difficile l'eau qui
porte le masque dont dans les transports
et les transports ne sont pas réellement
des lieux de contamination à certain
nombre de commerces ne sont pas
réellement lieu de contamination
donc je tout ça pour vous dire que plus
une mesure peut s'appuyer sur une donnée
scientifique
on peut raconter l'histoire à nos
citoyens et expliquer pourquoi tel ou
tel type de mesure est prise
plus elle est crédible plus en établir
un climat de confiance
mais malheureusement dans cette
pathologie les données que nous avons
elles sont relativement récentes sur la
question vraiment simple banal de dire
mais où est-ce qu'on se contaminent
comment se contaminent salon se
contaminent bien sûr la fois par eux
envoyé ryan et paroisse tactile et d'où
l'expression des mesures de démesure de
protection mais c'est trois études qui
sont toutes les trois concordants et
l'étude arnaud fontanet qui a été
réalisé d'abord dans une première
période sur du 1er au 15 octobre puis
ensuite du 1er au 15 décembre puis
ensuite maintenant sur la période avec
une dette de restrictions et de m'aider
couvre-feu retrouve son solide parce
qu'on retrouve à chaque fois finalement
les données qui peuvent qui peuvent être
faites
alors sur la notion d des flux et des
transports qui étaient là aussi de notre
première question oui après avoir dit
qu'il ya c'est aller le talion se
contaminent ou haute à l'autre on nous
le le risque ne paraît pas tellement
plus important chaque fois qu'il ya du
rassemblement un homme multiplie dans
une certaine mesure le risque de
transmission ccc assez claire quand même
donc c'est une c'est une vraie question
mais inversement
inversement vous avez vu que on se
trouve dans une situation en france à la
fois vis-à-vis des variés on n'est pas
seulement vis-à-vis des variants alors
qu'eux-mêmes conte alice et je dirais la
circulation
que vous évoquiez monsieur le député sur
deux se fait entre différentes régions
de france et bien malgré cette gérer
cette forme de liberté dans une certaine
mesure
vous avez des régions de france qui sont
beaucoup plus atteindre que l'autre et
d'autres qui sont moins éteinte
c'est en partie lié au phénomène des
grandes et des grandes métropoles mais
pas seulement pas seulement et vous
savez qu'il ya une sorte de carte on à
l'ouest de la france qui jusqu'à
maintenant est relativement protégé à la
fois vis-à-vis des variants et des deux
niveaux de contamination relativement
élevé et qu'il ya une partie centrale et
est ce qui a été beaucoup plus touchés
bon par ailleurs sur le problème delà
des frontières c'est un sujet complexe
qui est sur lequel les états européens
jusqu'à maintenant répandu avec une
vision européenne
ce que je peux vous dire moi je n'ai pas
je n'ai pas entrer là dedans dans cette
discussion qui est une discussion
évidemment politique
je resterai dans le sanitaire et pour
vous dire que le variant angles et les
déjà en france et et c'est il ya on a
toujours eu de la circulation avec
l'angleterre
quand on peut imaginer qu'on va retarder
l'arrivée du variant sud africain dans
la métropole pendant un certain temps
mais quand il va finir par arriver parce
qu'il y aura des contaminations qui
arriveront de toute façon est par contre
il est déjà arrivé parce qu'il y avait
des liens qu'ils étaient forts
au nom de quoi les couper parce que
l'afrique du sud jusqu'à maintenant les
pays africains étaient très peu touché
par la contamination
au nom de quoi des coupés avec la
réunion et avec eux et avec mayotte 1 c
c'est donc c'est donc ce virus il est
transporté par les hommes les hommes ont
des contacts
faut-il bloquer l'ensemble de la
circulation c'est une question qui est
politique et sur laquelle je ne souhaite
pas entrer deuxièmement sur le
financement de la recherche
en fait que n'ayant pas de vaccin
français entre guillemets et là problème
de souveraineté
bon ça rejoint une question la fois de
la recherche académique des start up qui
ne dépasserait à ce soir mais aussi de
des big pharma on a une très grande
ville format en france qui est pourtant
une spécialiste de vaccin qui est celle
fille et qui pour des raisons diverses
ils le reconnaissent eux mêmes a eu je
dirais un départ pas dans les meilleures
conditions sur la mise au point d'un
vaccin
il se lance terme de doses de vaccins
yal donc en effet nous ne sommes pas au
rendez vous de la production d'un vaccin
plus qu'à dans l'immédiat c'est à dire
qu'on sera pas au rendez vous ont rendez
vous à l'automne dans le quatrième
trimestre de l'année 2020 tient bon et
pour l'instant donc c'est en effet ces
vaccins qui sont issus de recherches
académiques pour certains on voit bien
là strazeele et cas avec oxford où de
grandes start up comme comme pfizer avec
la start up allemande
ce ne sont pas en effet pour l'instant
un an pas été je dirais issus de
recherches directement issus de
laboratoires français vous avez vu
également que le vaccin rougeole avec
porté par par le virus de la rougeole
s'est arrêté dans la collaboration qui
avait ainsi du passeur entre ainsi du
masters et merck
parce que les premiers résultats
n'étaient pas suffisamment de solide par
rapport aux données déjà existantes par
les vaccins c'est la recherche sellers
et puis il y aura probablement un retour
de sanofi à un moment donné alors est-ce
que c'est lié aux problèmes du
financement barcia je vais pas me lancer
là dedans
sachez seulement je vais vous donner un
chiffre que quand on regarde les
publications sur le co vide depuis le
début de la pandémie
la france ya des des systèmes de
classement qui permet de le faire est en
cinquième position
c'est à dire c'est notre classement
assez habituel à vrai dire on est en
cinquième ou sixième position dans la
recherche en biologie ce sont des
données issues d'une étude ville
biométrique réalisé par reacting et et
l'inserm
les questions autour de la démocratie
sanitaire et de la communication la
sénatrice vous on se connait nous sommes
connus au ccn en effet c'est un domaine
qui ont fâché
voilà que qui m'est cher 1 ce triangle
de
de construction entre le politique qui
décide
le scientifique qui est clair et le
citoyen qui donne aussi son éclairage et
je pense que la notion man et c'est de
cette démocratie en santé est construite
sur ce type
elle n'a pas été tellement rendez vous
disons le dans cette crise covin parce
que sidération parce que tout une série
de raisons parce que beaucoup de top
d'arn par certains côtés et on est dans
des situations de crise je le regrette
je suis comme vous nous avions que le
conseil scientifique qui avait souhaité
avoir la constitution d'un comité
citoyen de liaison je voulais rappeler
finalement ça s'est fait ça s'est fait
avec eux le comité autour du vaccin et
surtout ça s'est fait en région
finalement c'est peut-être mieux que ça
soit pas centralisé comme nous on avait
une idée centrale un peu trop d'ailleurs
et ça s'est fait en région vous avez ce
type de comités citoyens en relation
avec des scientifiques existent à
grenoble quasi ça lyon est en train de
se monter à paris qui existe à
strasbourg qui existe à rennes et où il
ya une discussion avec les autorités
régionales les grandes les merdes et les
responsables de grandes métropoles qui
s'est fait donc elle existe elle est
arrivée avec un peu de retard et mais
elle est là elle existe sur ce dont on
m'accuse et sur les problèmes de
communication m'accuser je dirais entre
guillemets entre dire l'urgence et
l'extrême urgence non je maintiens ma
position je nous n'avons le conseil
scientifique n'a jamais recommandé dès
début janvier relisez nos relisez no no
no no texte qu'il fallait rentrer dans
le confit demandé début janvier sont
arrêtés on a dit attention surveillants
voyant ce qui se passe après les fêtes
de noël et et du 31 janvier regardons ce
qui se passe et il faut penser à avoir
une surveillance active à partir de la
mi janvier on a évoqué différents
scénarios en fonction de l'arrivée des
variants bon et puis je maintiens ma
position thiel pour eux sur une décision
vous voyez bien que la situation en ce
moment les services de réanimation ne
sont pas non plus totalement plein enfin
on on voit bien la tension qu'il peut y
avoir entre une vision sanitaire de dire
il faut absolument faire quelque chose
pour aider
t pour éviter un drame entre guillemets
à la mi mars ou à la fin mars
et puis de l'autre côté je vous ai
entendu aussi attention il ya la santé
mentale des plus jeunes
là il ya une acceptabilité en population
qui devient qui va vite il va devenir
difficile
donc on voit bien que c'est une ces deux
sens ce sont des décisions qui mérite
d'être pensé réfléchi construite et avec
des propositions c'est là où je voulais
indiqué le médecin le pauvre medecin que
je suis vous indiquer qu'il ya une
différence entre un gamin de 18 ans qui
vient de se planter sur le pays il faut
trois équipes chirurgicales pour le père
et c'est dans l'eure et puis il faut y
aller vite et puis vous avez un cas
difficile qui demande à faire une irm
des examens radiologiques et on a deux
trois jours pour faire un diagnostic et
il ya les dérange c'est ça que je
distingue entre l'extrême urgence et
l'urgence mais bien sûr qu'il ya urgence
à une semaine 1
il ya urgence à une semaine n'y a pas
une semaine il ya pas urgence à deux
trois jours c'est ça que j'aime bien
indiqué alors la maladie parce que vides
le coc vide blond oui c'est une très
bonne question et c'est vrai qu'on en
parle un peu moins mais sachez qu'il ya
des recherches qui sont en cours sur le
sujet il ya plusieurs corps tu sur le
suivi des patients que vides de ce type
qui existent qui sont menées par la
mairesse fighting la nouvelle agence de
recherche qui existe depuis le 1er
janvier sur différentes vous avez
locales et les aspects pulmonaire il y
en a d'autres
il ya également des aspects
cardiovasculaires neurologique qui
existent si chic et rock existe et donc
il ya il y aura un colloque autour du
coc vite de longue durée du coc vie de
long qui sera organisée par la mairesse
reacting je dirais d'ici normalement en
fonction des événements bien sûr mais
d'ici deux mois de mars et il ya des
relations entre cette corde et des
données que nous avons également avec
nos collègues lequel également et nos
collègues anglais car eux sachez aussi
que dans la construction borthers et des
questions de recherche opérationnelle on
essaie comme le comité scientifique
d'avoir énormément de relations
énormément avec les étrangers moi j'ai
passé mon temps là au cours des quinze
derniers jours à des call avec les
anglais les sud africains les brésiliens
et les californiens un plus plus qu'à la
limite avec le modèle français pour
essayer de
de me renseigner au maximum la question
finalement de est-ce qu'on a eu
d'évaluation des stratégies de
politiques publiques
et est ce qu'on est capable de dire si
un couvre-feu à 18 heures quelle quelle
conséquence il a un confinement là et
qui ont un confinement dur alors c'est
une vraie grande question est difficile
dans un contexte de crise et qui n'est
pas dans les habitudes françaises
l'évaluation de politique de stratégie
de politique publique que ce soit dans
le domaine de la santé
on évalue finalement les décisions qui
ont été prises pour savoir de telle ou
telle façon
néanmoins là elles se sont elles se sont
faites elles se sont fait et ce qu'on
peut dire c'est par exemple sur votre
question autour du couvre-feu à 18
heures on a maintenant une expérience
sur un certain nombre de territoires de
plus de façon un peu plus anciennes et
plus récentes et on a quatorze quinze
jours sur les plus récents il ya une
efficacité par un majeur mais à un petit
peu sur la circulation
je dirais du virus en général mais
aucune efficacité sur la circulation et
sur la pénétration des variole voilà je
me lave simple en terme de résumer c'est
à dire qu'on contrôle
globalement avec le couvre-feu qui est
quand même déjà quelque chose de
difficile à 18 heures finalement une
circulation du virus et donc les
conséquences qu'il peut y avoir un mais
néanmoins quand même avec certaines
zones c'est pas du tout contrôler et on
voit bien en particulier en région paca
ou en région franche comté et où la
circulation n'est absolument pas
contrôlé par le couvre-feu à 18 heures
il manque donc quelque chose et là
dessus vient se rajouter le problème le
problème de la pénétration du vaio s
qu'une stratégie de territoire pourrait
être mise en place
oui elle a été jusqu'à maintenant peu
appliquée après et nous l'avons en effet
recommandé comme un des scénarios
possibles c'est à dire d'avoir quelque
chose qui associerait couvre-feu strict
voire une compris pendant le week-end
plus du confinement du confinement sur
certaines régions qui seraient
particulièrement touchés donc
une politique de territoire alors elle
est possible il faut qu'elle soit
pleinement bien expliquer là aussi
lorsque vous imaginez que les régions
qui qui sont confinés celles qui ne le
sont pas au nom de quoi
sur quelles marques sur quels indices
sur quel le choc
sur quoi se basent ce type de décision
mais c'est explicable
il ya des marqueurs et c'est la question
que vous posez vous les connaissez
d'ailleurs ils sont donnés sur lequel on
pourrait s'appuyer et en particulier un
des marqueurs vous avez bien compris qui
va être très important là dans les
semaines qui viennent
c'est le pourcentage de variants dans
tel ou tel dans telle ou telle zone qui
va être partie tués en vingt ans après
par rapport à une stratégie plus globale
de type l'ensemble du territoire
là c'est à mes yeux véritablement aussi
une décision de vue politique alors sur
l'ensemble des questions monsieur mila
nigou m'avait posée à la fin les
traitements ça c'est une excellente
question
parce que on est focalisé sur les
vaccins et je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
où l'avez peut-être pas noté je croyais
beaucoup à la période des traitements et
à l'arrière
pourquoi parce que les vaccins vont vont
permettre de protéger les plus anciens
contre les formes graves mais d'abord on
va pas tous les protéger et donc qui est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait je dirai à la fois
pour ceux qui n'ont pas bien répondu au
vaccin et en attendant qu'ils soient
vaccinés
est ce qu'une des solutions en effet ne
serait pas de traiter immédiatement les
plus anciens de façon à réduire la
mortalité morbidité
alors pour s' est ce qu on a des outils
alors on commence alors d'abord on a une
longue période sans traitement que
laisser ma position elle est écrite dans
le dans un avis du conseil scientifique
de juillet on a attendu d'avoir
l'ensemble de résultats des grands hits
internationaux je dirais pour prendre
une position claire
nous n'avons
pas de médicaments spécifiques ayant
fait la preuve de son efficacité
directement dirigés contrôle qu'ovide
jusqu'à la période du mois de jusqu'à la
fin de l'année en plus qu à 2020 donc
c'est vrai pour l'hydraulique l'origine
c'est vrai pour le rem désir c'est vrai
pour eux les anciens traitement du vih
comme les kaletra il n'y a pas de règle
alors quelles sont les nouvelles on a
les anticorps les cocktails d'anticorps
monoclonaux qui sont des anticorps
dirigés contre certaines protéines du
virus y en particulier la protéine spike
qui viennent la donne lors de trois
essais de faire la preuve de leur
efficacité qui doivent être donné très
tôt très tôt parce que en fait une des
vraies questions autour des traitements
c'est non seulement les molécules qu'on
utilise mais c'est le moment où on les
donne
vous savez qu'il ya plusieurs parties
dans cette maladie et à une partie
virale puis ensuite il ya une partie
inflammatoires et après il ya une partie
pour les formes des formes graves et si
on donne ces anticorps monoclonaux sur
sur ses succès de façon très précoce on
peut je dirais bloquer la bloquer la
multiplication du virus
un deuxième traitement est probablement
tourner autour des traitements par
l'interféron et sur lesquelles il ya
ainsi une série interféron alpha ou
interféron bêta et sur lequel il ya une
série d'essais qui démarre suite à des
études de physio pathogénique d'un
français jean laurent cazes est la loi
qui a qui a pu mettre en évidence
mécanisme des défauts de production de
l'interféron particulier dans les formes
graves et puis on a une troisième
on a on a un ou deux nouvelles molécules
de deuxième ou de troisième génération
c'est-à-dire directement ciblés comme
antiviraux contre le virus lui-même qui
sont en phase 1 et 2 sur lequel je peux
rien dire mais sachez qu'il ya des
recherches dessus et puis enfin on a des
stratégies qui pourraient s'appuyer sur
les sérums issus de convalescent et où
deux convalescents vacciner c'est à dire
qu'ils ont une réponse immunitaire
extrêmement forte poussée éventuellement
par le vaccin et qui pourraient être
utilisés donc voilà sur la transparence
sur la vitamine d dans les traitements
oui les données sont pas sont pas je
dirais ma silva sûr mais je veux dire on
est tous
en particulier chez les sujets âgés de
mon âge les reins pendant la période
on appelle d'hiver plutôt en carence de
vitamine est donc à condition de pas ce
bois est une vitamine d tout les jours
qui peut entraîner une pathologie et de
prendre raisonnablement sa son ampoule
de calais calciférol une fois par mois
eh bien ça ne peut pas faire de mal je
dirais dans la lutte globale contre le
virus
mais il faut être prudent surtout de ne
pas prendre de la vitamine t tous les
jours parce que les intoxications la
vitamine d ça existe la transparence et
la biblio oui c'est mais les avis du cul
des comités scientifiques sont sur le
site du ministère on n'a pas de site
propre de ils sont payés font ils sont
parfaitement donc accessible au grand
public
la biblio sur les études depuis les mais
logique sur lesquels on s'appuie et dans
nos avis à une biographie en général
dans la plupart de nos avis et puis par
ailleurs le site de pasteur william à
des mobilisateurs qui est issu de
l'institut pasteur a mis aussi sur nos
sur le fameux ces fameux calcul en effet
de survenue d'incidence
d'hospitalisation ils sont maintenant
public depuis ie depuis début décembre
confiné les plus âgés c'est un débat
difficile je le présenterai autrement je
dirais que dans le contexte actuel
proposé aux personnes les plus âgées les
plus fragiles de d'effectuer une sorte
d'auto isolement ou de protection plutôt
appeler comme ça d'auto protection
individuelle
il peut être proposé mais c'est à eux de
décider
c'est eux qui décident ce n'est pas pas
et on est là on doit demander dans le
respect de la personne
ce sont eux qui décident et c'est leur
rappeler en effet que ça
ce que je lui dise sur la contamination
la contamination est possible y compris
chez soi domicile pour une personne qui
pense se protéger qui à la limite ne va
plus faire ses courses mais accueille
une de personnes chez elles sans prendre
de précautions il faut ils font pas la
couper du reste
de son tissu social on est tous d'accord
là dessus mais lui rappeler les règles
de protection y compris chez elle et au
moment des repas en particulier donc
est-ce que ça suffirait c'est la
deuxième question
cette stratégie la réponse est non parce
que et heureusement
et heureusement il ya une porosité entre
générateur générationnel en france qui
existe entre la population la plus jeune
les parents et les grands parents et ses
essais c'est humain et il faut on va pas
le changer
et donc il ya cette porosité conduit à
partir du moment où on a trop de
circulation du virus dans la population
jeune à une transmission progressive
dans la population la puisaye on a
toutes les données là dessus qu'ils
montent cette porosité dans ce qui s'est
passé au mois de septembre sur un
certain nombre de grandes métropoles où
on voit au départ une transmission une
circulation du virus uniquement la
population jeune avec eux ce qui s'est
passé au début des rentrées
universitaires et cetera et puis
progressivement ça rentre dans la
population la plus âgée
je rappelle que la suède qui a eu cette
attitude finalement de de laisser vivre
entre guillemets en auto isolant plus ou
moins bien d'ailleurs les populations
âgées est revenue complet complètement à
180° sur sa stratégie
il ya il ya maintenant deux mois voilà
bah écoutez je crois que j'ai répondu à
peu près à une série de l'occasion
j'avais encore j'ai encore noté quoi les
conflits d'intérêts par les conflits
d'intérêts au sein du du le complotisme
des conflits d'intérêts oui y'a ne
confondons pas une fois de plus des ce
qui est conflits d'intérêts et ceux qui
est la déclaration
la déclaration d'intérêts oui bien sûr
je vais demander à l'ensemble des
membres du conseil scientifique
c'est il ya un règlement intérieur
d'ailleurs qui est disponible également
sur le site comme on sait assez peu
intéressée à l'aspect des traitements
jeu comme je voulais indiqué sana ça n'a
pas ça la paille ça ne pas il n'y a pas
tellement eu finalement d'enjeux majeurs
là dessus néanmoins j'ai demandé quand
même à deux ou trois personnes chaque
fois qu'on parlait des traitements de se
retirer de la discussion
et de se mettre ce qu'on appelle en
débord et on l'a fait très régulièrement
moi même je déclare que je n'ai pas de
conflit d'intérêts est ce que je me suis
fait vacciner
la réponse est oui et je me suis fait
vacciner
je rappelle que j'ai 72 ans donc que je
n'ai pas droit au vaccin et que je suis
soignants puisque j'ai une consultation
à bicêtre et que c'est à ce titre là en
tant que soignant ayant une consultation
dans mon hôpital que j'ai été vacciné
c'est une preuve j'ai eu une première
vaccination avec le vaccin finder
écoutez je crois que j'ai répondu à peu
près à l'ensemble de vos questions je
confirme ya alors sur la danse dans
toute la liste que j'avais que j'avais
que j'avais marqué juste la solidité des
études des dossiers montés par pfizer
moderna à travers le l'ensemble écoutez
je ne la question serait plus en fait
pour allah fischer ou marie paule kieny
qui ont étudié en détail dans le détail
non seulement les publications que moi
j'ai vu bien sûr mais le dossier
d'enregistrement ainsi auquel ils ont eu
accès sont des dossiers qui font 500 600
pages etc
pour en avoir discuté avec eux en tout
cas pour les deux dossiers à mairena il
semble que ça soit des dossiers
extrêmement solide
après on est dans une atmosphère de
pression d'accélération éventuellement
des dossiers d'aena
ce qui me rassure un peu ces voiliers le
délai avec lequel je prends en
particulier l'agencé européenne pour
donner un feu vert pour le vaccin
astrazeneca
alors certains prennent ce set
cet état en disant regardez une fois de
plus comme les européens sont lents pour
donner un feu vert
on peut aussi se dire que peut-être s'il
ne donne pas le feu vert aussi
rapidement que ça c'est que le dossier
le pose un certains nombre peut-être de
questions sur la totale solidité de ce
vaccin et sur le fait qu'il n'est
peut-être pas tout à fait à la hauteur
étant avec ça intéressant néanmoins
probablement il est peut-être pas à la
hauteur en termes de résultats les deux
vaccins ameren a donc il ya quand même
un processus d'évaluation qui est sous
pression et c'est là où il faut faire
attention à la fois au niveau de
l'europe et de la vie des américaines
les vous a eu que pour la première fois
se trouve ça très important de se
rejoindre les aspects de démocratie
sanitaire
l'afd a rendu à fait la discussion
publique de l'acceptation des vaccins
freezer et des vaccins des vaccins
moderna je croise était 10 heures de
séance et 10 heures c'était public et
c'était sur le net
c'est la première fois que ça arrive
elle a étudié ou en général on considère
que ce type de discussion est d'ordre
scientifique et un peu privé par
certains côtés et là ils ont souhaité le
rendre public
c'est aussi une des forces c'est qu'on
l'a beaucoup discuté récemment et de la
démocratie américaine
je pense qu'il faut qu'on en prenne un
certain nombre de leçons voici l'un de
mes regrets je vais vous dire c'est un
peu tard puis c'est difficile mais c'est
de ne pas c'est de ne pas d'une certaine
mesure rendre de temps en temps des
séances du comité scientifique publique
merci beaucoup chaque professeur pour
nous autres parlementaires qui sommes
habitués à voir un au débat public sans
arrêt ce que vous dites fait
complètement sens des fois on a besoin
de confidentialité aussi dans certaines
occasions et trouver le bon dosage est
important mais il est vrai que notre
époque a besoin de transparence
mes chers collègues nous arrivons au
terme de cette audition merci beaucoup
professeur delfraissy pour avoir pris
nettement plus que le temps que nous
nous étions initialement fixée afin de
répondre à toutes les questions qui ont
été là merci au rapporteur pour le
travail continue sur ce sur ce sujet qui
est extraordinairement plein de
paramètres de complications merci aux
parlementaires de l'eau texte pour leur
rôle actif toujours merci aux citoyens
qui se sont connectés et qu'ils ont et
qu'ils ont posé des questions aussi que
j'espère avoir transcrites de façon
assez fidèle et
je vous souhaite à tous et toutes une
bonne soirée en attendant la suite de
nos travaux je vous remercie
merci beaucoup merci à tous bon soir au
revoir professeur merci beaucoup